hey GameSpot historical shooters are  back in fashion and we got a chance to  play Rising Storm to Vietnam  it's a squad based game with tactical  elements that reminds us of older  battlefield games and I mean that in a  good way  here are a couple of triple kills and  one dumb grenade kill because reasons  are they guys if you're interested in  upcoming first-person shooters from  World War one - or Vietnam or maybe just  want us to stream some battlegrounds let  us know what the like or subscribe let's  get to the jungle  Scout reporting we are looking for um  taking Charlie Scout  return to combat so weird to play straps  play straps guys Rita  you